speaking of um I
guess traits that people are looking to
pass on I saw the weirdest Twitter post
okay I don't think I've been this
Bamboozled and just like confused in a
long time let's pull it up so there's a
woman that tweeted hello Twitter peeps
my friend Elizabeth is looking for an
unvaccinated sperm donor her
requirements are blue-eyed white 511 or
taller STD
no Jewish or African ancestry follows a
healthy meat focused diet must be a
natural insemination she will not do IVF
DM
me
um her details are J German and Swedish
ancestry a two body count been celibate
the last 2.5 years 23 years old
unvaccinated meat focused diet
supplements D3 and K2 will have support
of grandmother and younger brother
insemination must be natural in person
in eastern USA she was not looking for a
husband or boyfriend she will remain
celibate after this what the
um your schedule must be free to
accommodate her ovulation schedule she
will give you as much notice as possible
she has decided not to go up she has
decided not to go through with the
upfront fee so don't worry about that
she is asking that you remain in touch
for future reinsemination as she is
looking to have three children over the
next 5 years as you can see she is
incredibly beautiful pure-blooded
European intelligent and has a
childbearing body your offspring will be
raised extremely well please DM me your
application I will be in touch for
further details if she deems you
qualified I know I saw I I was like this
cannot be real Tristan Tate comments
disgusting I know I know that it's so
funny your reaction that was mine I'm
like this can't this has got to be fake
this has got your offspring will be
raised very well yeah we know how these
stories with single moms go why would
you pick that why would you like why on
Earth would you choose to be a single
mother literally and I think it shows
something about society and their lack
of appreciation for fathers you need a
strong masculine figure in the kid's
life and she's picking this I actually
am quite speechless for me it's it's
really quite scary because what we are
seeing is a a public admittance to
Eugenics I mean listen to the wording
pure blooded yeah you know she's got all
of these things she's this is completely
evil and unnatural completely you know
like Tristan says disgusting disgusting
absolutely disgusting dehumanizing of
view to suggest that a man should be
willing and able to casually agree to
this kids need their fathers and fathers
need their
children absolutely abs absolutely and I
completely agree you know that's a
that's a big issue here I'm just I'm
more concerned about the the humanity if
issue of this this is this is this is
this is evil this is really evil I don't
think she's
23 I just I'm not buying does she look
23 to you that was she looks like she
needs to be behind bars this is really
bad those things that she's saying is
like that's what led us into World War
II that's you know the I know we can't
say his name on YouTube but the guy who
was the leader of Germany this is that
same ideology yeah and she's publicly
admitted oh God I I don't know if we're
going to see the eugenic stuff per se as
much but I think we're going to see more
of the sper donor where women just like
are not going to want to pay the cost
yeah where so they they just essentially
just want kids but they don't want their
kids to have a dad well they don't think
they can get the type of guy that they
would want keep do you know what I mean
so I I think it's them picking I want
people not understand like how DNA
works I don't know these people are
crazy I I just saw this I was like you
think oh right so if the guy is not
around purely based on environmental
factors I'm going to be able to mold
this child into what I want do do you
not realize that you know literally
everything is in our DNA no just get a
sperm donor yeah just amazing that I'm
sure this is going to work out well for
her um okay actually shocked
me I seriously I saw this and I was like
what on Earth because I'm like okay let
me get this straight your okay let me
get this straight lady your idea of kids
that are going to be raised well is
putting out an application on on
Twitter Twitter okay all right all right
um please no one give this woman no yeah
guys there's someone's going to do it
someone's going to come on someone's
going to do it um so I wanted to talk
about you know I think the theme is
women being just so out of pocket and I
started thinking about how we really got
to this point like how do we get so
delusional and crazy and I thought about
a show that actually was super popular
when I was in high school okay do you
have you heard of Gray's Anatomy yes
okay I'm going to show you a clip from
it okay and I want to see what you
notice pull it up love you
April I always
have I love everything about you even
the things I don't
like I
love and I want you with
me I love you and I think that you love
me
too a
time and you April and Matthew closest
friends and family are here today to
Bear witness to their Union will you
promise to love and support their
marriage in all the days to come if so
please respond we
will
now I I have known the two of you for
quite some
time I'm sorry stand up I'm happy to be
here today to be able to do this for
[Music]
you
I don't know
[Music]
do what did you notice from this
clip why didn't her husband who she's
actually getting married to punch him in
the
face first of all
okay why was everyone acting like this
was this really beautiful amazing moment
that like like two lovers have it's the
whole like Romeo and Juliet [__]
like two lovers have just they've just
realized their love for each other how's
that going to work out long term how how
are you guys then going to get married
you know and what you're not you're not
going to remember this whole thing where
like she was about to get married and
then I mean judging by the the tone of
that scene I imagine I'm not seeing
Gray's Anatomy but I imagine she goes
yes I love you too and they have this
moment where they realize they love for
each other
like why why why I just can't understand
why I do I do know they date for a
couple years in the show my sister's
watched it so like sometimes I would
watch a couple episodes but I never was
that into it I noticed something else
okay one why is the ex-boyfriend at the
wedding right cuz they dated before Oh
my God yeah yeah yeah um two what would
you rate her 1 to 10 um
five four oh I actually I was going to
give her a six okay six maybe five six
that's what I would say I just feel she
look like she'd had some weet on okay
maybe five whatever whatever okay let's
just say she's a five normal looking
chick why how does she get now she has
two eights or higher fighting over her I
was like this is the most unrealistic
thing I have ever seen in my life you're
telling me this average chick has two
men the the one guy in the in the um the
one guy I know the one guy is a doctor I
don't remember what the other guy does
the one guy that like got up okay you're
telling me Jackson Avery okay Jesse
Williams one of like very attractive
dude second very attractive dude are
fighting over a six a five in what world
in what world I'm like it's no wonder
we're so delusional because you have all
of these shows showing average women
getting these amazing results I mean
also why why did everyone just passively
sit there and let this unfold like let's
believe if this was happening in real
life if I was about to get married right
first of all my ex wouldn't even be
there but let's say your ex is there
right yeah for whatever messed up
deluded reason he stands up SP my family
are going what the hell get out of here
what are you doing
you're embarrassing get out what is
going on but no everyone's just like oh
look at this beautiful moment where they
realize their love what it goes back to
and I think it shows something about the
culture right and it goes back to the
theme of The One That Got Away yeah and
yeah it's a very common theme that we
see in the media and the culture we had
a song that I mean you know the Katy
Perry kry The One That Got Away the one
that wrecked my heart I should have
never let him go I should have begged
him to stay he was the one that got away
and so I think that you really have a
generation of women there's a reason
that that show was so popular the theme
of the main character which is Meredith
also it's the one that got away she in
the beginning hooks up with this doctor
right that she's whatever then he goes
back she finds out he's still
technically married and then the whole
thing is like this love triangle same
with you know Olivia Pope have you ever
seen it's this other other show this
girl named Olivia Pope she's the side
chick to the president and it's always
he was the one that got away it's like
we see all these seeds planted within
our culture and then we wonder why we're
growing [__] crops exactly yeah because
again really in a truly an honest thing
it would be the women fighting over him
you are not going to have two grown men
that are doctors in their mid-30s like
okay maybe at 22 some guys are naive Oh
I thought you brought me on here for a
bit of fun you know I thought it's going
to be fun I'm going to have to go away
and S dark room cuz you're just
destroying my faith in humanity right
now sorry that's what I do best anyways
so the comments say wrong timing to me
very selfish on his end what about the
others
correct but why would you wait for her
wedding day yeah I'm like how long was
the average engagement it's so funny the
average dating period before getting
engaged is three years the average
engagement is one year M so I'm like
you've had like four years also I think
that shows you that a woman probably
wrote wrote this because chances of a
man doing that very low chances of a
woman doing that very high yeah exactly
so it should have been flipped it would
have been more likelyhood is it would
have been a woman who stood up and said
you know but that's this is what they're
trying to do they're trying to flip the
order of things and tell you that this
is what could happen no absolutely not
yeah no guy no guy is going to do that
especially with like a bigger like he
looks tall and good shap also I'm more
looking at it from the perspective of
the fact that women are more selfish so
women are the ones less likely to
consider the fact oh this is their
wedding day you know maybe I shouldn't
do that for their sake if I love them
then I'm not going to embarrass them on
their wedding day I think a woman is
more likely to go ah [__] all of that
this is how I feel about it